>>> TOP OFFICIALS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY JUST
ANNOUNCED A HISTORY-MAKING
SCIENTIFIC ACHIEVEMENT
ACCOMPLISHING A DECADES LONG
QUEST TO HARNESS FUSION THAT
POWERS THE SUN AND STARS.
RENE MARSH HAS MUCH MORE DETAIL.
WHAT DID WE JUST HEAR FROM THE
ENERGY DEPARTMENT ON THIS WHAT
AND DOES IT MEAN FOR THE FUTURE
OF CLEAN ENERGY?
>> YEAH, SO THE SCIENTISTS AT
THIS DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY LAB IN
CALIFORNIA, THEY HAVE
EFFECTIVELY FIGURED OUT HOW TO
BOTTLE THE SUN.
THEY WERE USING 192 LIT HIGH
POWER LASERS TO FORCE AND HEAT
FUSING THE ATOMS TOGETHER,
UNLEASHING THIS POWER THAT
REPLICATES THE CONDITIONS THAT
WE SEE IN THE SUN AND THE STARS.
BUT ON DECEMBER 5th, THAT IS
WHEN THE BREAKTHROUGH HAPPENED
FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME, THIS
FUSION PROCESS PRODUCED MORE
ENERGY THAN WAS USED BY THE
LASERS TO DRIVE IT.
AND THAT IS SO CRITICAL.
IN ORDER FOR ANYTHING TO BE A
VIABLE ENERGY SOURCE, THE OUTPUT
OF ENERGY MUST FAR OUTWEIGH THE
INPUT OF ENERGY USED TO GENERATE
IT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY
SECRETARY JENNIFER GRANHOLM
SAYING THIS IS ONE OF THE FEATS
OF THE CENTURY AND THIS IS MORE
THAN 60 YEARS IN THE MAKING.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> IT TOOK NOT JUST ONE
GENERATION BUT GENERATIONS OF
PEOPLE PURSUING THIS GOAL.
AND IT IS A SCIENTIFIC
MILESTONE, SCIENTIFIC ENERGY
BREAK EVEN TO ACHIEVE THIS.
BUT OF COURSE AS WITH ALL OF
THESE KINDS OF COMPLEX SCIENT
ISK UNDERTAKINGS IT IS AN
ENGINEERING MARVEL BEYOND
BELIEF.
>> AND OF COURSE THIS IS NOT
JUST A BIG DEAL FOR THE
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY IT WILL
HAVE THE ABOUT TO CHANGE NOT THE
WAY NOT ONLY WE KPLUCONSUME AND
OUR SOURCE OF ENERGY FOR EVERY
DAY LIVES.
>> JOINING ME NOW IS THE
SECRETARY OF ENERGY JENNIFER
GRANHOLM.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
WHAT DOES THE MILESTONE MEAN FOR
THE QUEST FOR CLEAN ENERGY
SOURCES.
HO YOU WOULD YOU DESCRIBE IT
NOW?
>> THE FACT THAT WE HAVE BEEN
TRYING, WE AS A NATION, AS A
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY ACROSS THE
WORLD HAVE BEEN TRYING FOR OVER
60 YEARS TO ACHIEVE WHAT IS
KNOWN AS IGNITION, WHICH IS --
WAS DESCRIBED AND IT MEANS THAT
MORE ENERGY CAME OUT OF THE
REACTIONS THAN WERE PUT INTO IT.
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
THIS IS JUST A -- THIS IS ONE
EXPERIMENT.
BUT IT HAD NEVER BEEN ACHIEVED
BEFORE.
AND THAT MEANS THAT IT IS
POSSIBLE.
IT ESSENTIALLY UNLOCKED A WHOLE
NEW SOURCE OF CLEAN ENERGY.
NOW, YOU KNOW FUSION IS WHERE
TWO PARTICLES COME TOGETHER,
ATOMIC PARTICLES AND FISSION IS
WHERE YOU SPLIT AN ATOM.
AND SO THE SPLITTING CREATES
NUCLEAR WASTE.
THIS, THE FUSION, THE ATOM,
WHICH IS WHY FUSION IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT QUEST, CREATES NO
WASTE.
IF WE COULD GET THIS SCALE SO-T
WOULD BE AMAJOR ENDEAVOR OF
ACHIEVING THE GOAL OF ZERO
CARBON EMISSION POWER.
>> WE KNOW IT IS NOT TOMORROW.
BUT HOW LONG UNTIL YOU THINK
NUCLEAR FUSION CAN AND WILL
POWER HOMES, POWER BUSINESSES?
>> YEAH, I MEAN, THE REALLY
INTERESTING PART OF THIS, KATE,
IS THAT THERE IS A HUGE AMOUNT
OF PRIVATE SECTOR INTEREST IN
THIS.
SO THERE IS OBVIOUSLY BEEN VERY
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC INVESTMENTS,
WE'VE GONE 17 NATIONAL LABS, A
GOOD NUMBER OF THOEM ARE WORKIN
ON THESE SOLUTIONS.
BUT NOW THAT WE'VE GOTTEN CLOSER
AND CLOSER, THE PRIVATE SECTOR
IS ALSO VERY INTERESTED IN THIS.
SO THE PRESIDENT HAS A TEN-YEAR
GOLD OF GETTING TO A COMMERCIAL
FUSION REACTOR.
AND HE ANNOUNCED THAT GOAL THIS
PAST SUMMER.
SO WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WITH, YOU
KNOW, IN A DECADE, WE MIGHT BE
THERE.
WE HAVE A GOAL OF GETTING TO NET
ZERO ENERGY BY 2050 SO THAT
WOULD BE WITHIN THAT TIME FRAME.
AND BUT NOW THAT THIS
BREAKTHROUGH HAS HAPPENED, THE
SCIENTISTS COULD GO TO WORK ON
IMPROVING THE PROCESS.
OF MAKING, IN THIS PARTICULAR
TYPE OF FUSION, IT WAS WITH
LASERS.
SO THEY WOULD WORK ON MAKING THE
LASERS MORE POWERFUL.
THEY WORK ON OTHER ASPECTS OF
THE ACTUAL REACTION THAT MAKES
IT MORE POWERFUL, MORE OUTPUT.
BUT THERE IS A LOT MORE PROGRESS
THAT IS EVEN BEING MADE IN A
DIFFERENT KIND OF FUSION WITH
MAGNETS.
SO IT IS REALLY EXCITING TO SEE
THAT BOTH OF THESE TYPES OF
FUSION ARE BEING LOOKED AT BY
THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND THEY HAVE
EVERY INCENTIVE TO MOVE QUICKLY.
>> WHENEVER THIS IS A
COMPLISHED, THAT IS FANTASTIC.
BUT HERE IS WHY TIME DOES
MATTER.
ABOUT A FUZZ NATIONS AND THE OIL
INDUSTRY CONTINUE ON THE PATH
THEY'RE ON, BY THE TIME IT IS
COMMERCIALLY VIABLE ALL OF THE
WORST TIPPING POINTS WHEN IT
COMES TO THE CLIMATE CRISIS
COULD VERY WELL ALREADY BE
CROSSED.
WE COULD ALREADY BE TO THE POINT
OF NO RETURN.
AT THE SAME TIME THE PRESIDENT
SPENT A GOOD PART OF THIS PAST
YEAR TELLING OIL PRODUCERS LIKE
OPEC TO PRODUCE MORE BECAUSE OF
THE OTHER CRISES THAT WE'RE
FACING AROUND THE WORLD.
SO WHAT DO YOU DO ABOUT THAT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, IT IS CLEAR
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE ENOUGH
POWER TO GET PEOPLE TO PUT GAS
IN THEIR CARS AND TO HEAT THEIR
HOMES.
THAT IS THE NOW.
AND THE REALITY.
BUT WE ARE ACCELERATING THIS
TRANSITION TO A CLEAN ENERGY
FUTURE.
FUSION IS ONE OF THE PIECES, BUT
IT IS NOT ONLY PIECE.
IT HAS HUGE PROMISE BUT WE HAVE
A LOST WORK TO DO.
THAT IS WHY ACCELERATING CLEAN
ENERGY, WHETHER IT IS WIND OR
SOLAR OR CLEAN HYDROGEN, AND
ELECTRIFYING TRANSPORTATIONMENT
ALL OF THOSE THINGS THAT WERE
PASSED IN THE PRESIDENT'S
AGENDA, THROUGH THE INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT AND THE BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE LAW, THOSE ARE
ALL PROCEEDING WITH THE PEDAL TO
THE METAL.
SO WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT ALL
OF THOSE.
CLEARLY WE HAVE FIGURED OUT HOW
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DEPLOY
ENOUGH CLEAN ENERGY THROUGH
THESE INCENTIVES TO CUT OUR
EMISSIONS AS A NATION IN HALF BY
50% AND GET TO NET ZERO BY 2050.
BUT WE HAVE A LOT MORE WORK TO
MAKE SURE IT IS NOT JUST THE
UNITED STATES BUT OTHER
COUNTRIES AS WELL.
SO OUR EXAMPLE IN THE FUSION AS
WELL AS IN OTHER OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES AND POLICIES ARE
BEING LOOKED AT VERY SERIOUSLY
BY OTHER COUNTRIES WHO ALSO WANT
TO DO THEIR PART.
>> BEFORE WE GO, I DO WANT TO
ASK YOU ABOUT THE ENERGY
ASSISTANCE PROMISED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION TO UKRAINE TO
HELP REPAIR THE ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I BELIEVE IT WAS $53 MILLION
ANNOUNCED AND WAS PROMISED.
WHERE ARE YOU IN GETTING THAT
ASSISTANCE OVER TO UKRAINE?
>> YEAH, THE ASSISTANCE IS
REALLY IN THE FORM OF EQUIPMENT
TO REPAIR THEIR ELECTRIC GRID
WHICH AS YOU KNOW IS BEING
BOMBED ON A REGULAR BASIS BY
RUSSIA.
AND SO IN PARTNERING WITH OUR
UTILITIES ACROSS THE NATION,
WE'VE IDENTIFIED EQUIPMENT THAT
IS ACTUALLY RIGHT NOW AS WE
SPEAK IN TRANSIT TO UKRAINE AS
THE FIRST TRANCHE, IF YOU WILL,
OF EQUIPMENT THAT WE ARE SENDING
AS A NATION TO HELP -- TO HELP
UKRAINE.
THE DEPUTY ENERGY SECRETARY DAVE
TURK IS IN FRANCE RIGHT PLNOW.
THERE IS A CONFERENCE CONVENING
ALL OF THE COUNTRIES TO SEE WHAT
THEY COULD DO TO DONATE
EQUIPMENT, GET EQUIPMENT OVER TO
UKRAINE SO THAT THEY COULD TURN
ON THEIR LIGHTS AND POWER THEIR
HOMES DURING THE WINTER.
>> YEAH.
ZELENSKYY SAYING TODAY THAT 800
MILLION PLUS IS NEEDED IN ORDER
TO REVERSE THE DAMAGE DONE BY
THE EXTENSIVE BOMBING TO PROTECT
THEM THROUGH THE WINTER.
SO MUCH NEEDED AND IT IS HEADING
OVER THERE NOW.
SECRETARY, THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.